uh and now i'm going to blow your mind
and and this let me let me give you the
full
experience that caused me to come to
this conclusion
tuesday
of this week the league in the union
finalized a seven page letter agreement
setting forth the rules for the covet
opt-out this season and my first thought
was why bother who the hell is opting
out this year 67 guys opted out last
year and i think one of the reasons so
many did there was so much uncertainty
before their deadline of like early
august nobody had a chance to come to
training camp and give it a week or two
and see how they felt or give me a
couple of seasons or a couple of weeks
excuse me into the regular season let me
decide then how it feels he had to make
an early decision 67 guys did i'd say
most of them regret it in hindsight the
way things went this year why bother who
the hell is opting out okay that said
i i read the the letter agreement
yesterday and it's you know legalese and
the thick and you gotta read it
carefully and as i was reading it i'm
thinking
okay
i could see cole beasley opting out
because i'm not getting vaccinated and i
don't want to have to deal with the
rules that apply to players who aren't
vaccinated so this is a way for me to
press pause on my career and i'll come
back next year when this isn't an issue
that's one one guy i could think of that
would take advantage of this and then i
thought of aaron rodgers this is a get
out of jail free card this is a silver
bullet for him where he can opt out
take the entire year off not owe the
green bay packers 11 and a half million
in unearned signing bonus money not owe
them 2 million in fines that will accrue
if he skips training camp not forfeit
the 6.8 million dollar roster bonus that
he's already earned and will be paid out
this year it's 20.3 million total that
he would avoid if he opts out and and
what i did once i realized that that
power is there
i tried to find a reason to convince
myself it's not
so i i i found some language in the
agreement that made me think he can't do
it it's too easy it's too simple
and
and this is i i i went back and forth
with someone overnight and i looked at
the letter agreement again this morning
and you know what
he can
he has to make an irrevocable decision
by next friday
you and and and that's it it is final
but if he decides and informs the team
by next friday july 2nd that he's
sitting out for all of 2021 taking
advantage of the opt out right
he saves 20.3 million dollars and
what would happen next year they'd trade
him we get to where we would have been
anyway i don't i don't think he's going
to do it
but it's amazing to think he has a path
if he's truly thinking about sitting out
he has a path to do it that saves him
20.3 million dollars remember uh the
what was the show called it was life
lifestyles of the rich and famous with
robin leach right
yes i wish they did that for you
lifestyles of the rich and famous and
they showed up to to the barn and it's
just paper everywhere
paper everywhere trying to figure out
aaron rodgers loophole la la
opt-out for the covet protocol and
that's how mike florio sent his spent
his thursday it was fantastic yeah that
was that would generate that would
generate
it's uh charlie kelly pepe sylvia you're
just you're putting the the
uh pins we got it we got it there it is
no we got it there it is
conspiracy mike i listen i hope you're
right i hope you're right but oh man
that no that was the worst way to spend
your time ever
ever no it's not no it's not no no it's
not because if he does it if he does it
i was the only one saying that he may do
it
and and what is that guess what you get
guess what you get a little tiny trophy
of validation that's just
[Laughter]
being like oh mike you know who's gonna
steal it
i don't have to tell you who's gonna
steal it but other people will
definitely steal this take mike and
they'll probably get more credit for it
that that's all right that's all right
because i'm only trying to prove it to
myself got it i'm not trying to prove it
to anyone else
i love how you did the work
i it really didn't take that much work
or i would have gotten it right
yesterday afternoon i was trying so damn
hard to not go there yesterday it's like
there's no way this is too easy this is
too simple there's no way i'm trying to
speak it into existence not not because
i i care whether or not he plays this
year i actually think it's better for
our business if he does play for the
packers because the dysfunction will
just be wall-to-wall from the moment he
shows up until the moment their season
ends but if he is going
to stay away if that's what he's
intending to do
he had fallen to his lap on tuesday the
ultimate way to do it without losing
20.3 million so
i'll look at it this way
if he doesn't
opt out by next friday then that means
he is showing up and he was going to
show up all along okay
so i i love that you did this i i i now
have next friday circled hoping that he
opts out for uh mental health and i want
him to do it i want him to be happy
um
let's go back let's let's frame it in
the tom brady conversation we just had
if he did opt out what does that do to
aaron rodgers legacy because that
obviously changes things if he says i
don't want to play and people you know
you know how people feel about covet now
and now that we're on the other side of
the pandemic and if he uses it under the
guise of covid protocol because that's
kind of how he'll have to play it right
like he can't say i'm opting out because
i don't want to play for the green bay
packers he's saying i'm using the coven
protocol and i'm using the rules that
are set forth by the nfl and i'm opting
out before a safety issue
it would be
a difficult pr cell right and i think
what he would have to do
is and here's how i think he'd have to
couch it
i think he'd have to say i'm not doing
this because i'm concerned about covet
because the way
you don't have to be concerned you don't
have to be concerned about covet you
have a voluntary opt-out right that he's
been that's why i didn't believe it
yesterday that's why i didn't want to
believe it yesterday i wanted to read
the agreement to conclude that he could
only do it if he had developed some sort
of a condition since last october that
puts him in a high-risk category and
that's true if you want to get a 350 000
stipend for him who gives a crap about
the stipend he's trying to avoid owing
the packers 20.3 million what he would
have to do is sit down with a favorable
interviewer
and explain without getting a bunch of
tough questions
yeah you of course what do you have to
do is say
look here's how the nfl works there's a
bunch of rules out there that typically
are written for the benefit of the teams
and they put pressure on the players to
do things that maybe the players don't
want to do and i'm in the process of
trying to figure out do i want to play
for the green bay packers this year and
i had a rule fall out of the sky that
the nfl and the nflpa negotiated and the
way that i'm reading it and the way that
my agents are reading it it gives me the
ability to do what i was going to do
anyway
without owing the packers a bunch of
money that i've already been paid or
that i'm already entitled to we press
pause on the relationship for a year
so that's what we do and that's what i'm
doing i'm doing what i'm doing is no
different than what the team does when
they cut a guy from the roster when they
when they whatever that whatever rights
a team has applying the franchise tag
that's a right that arises in the rules
that these two sides have put together
it's not an easy argument for them to
make and there's gonna be a lot of
packers fans that aren't gonna like it
but my point is this if he's not gonna
play anyway if he's already decided i'm
not showing up this year it's it's
ridiculous
for him to not take advantage of a path
that avoids a 20.3 million dollar
difference if he just stays away all
year long versus if he opts out by next
friday that's my point yeah for 20.3
million you can go hire the best pr firm
in the world to give you a way to
explain why you're doing what you're
doing okay another question if he does
opt out on friday by friday next friday
there's no chance he can come back this
year correct
is it right it's done
okay so that's why i think he's not
gonna do it because i think in the back
of his head he's saying to himself if i
just keep pushing this the packers will
eventually trade me and if they don't
trade me i'll just play football and
i'll just hate everyone and not talk to
anyone in that facility and be aaron
rodgers and make a lot of money and
probably win a bunch of games and losing
an nfc playoff game and blame everyone
but myself and call it a year and then
figure it out next year that's probably
what he'll do i mean that's
hey that's why russell wilson's back in
seattle there was a report from espn
earlier this week that russell wilson's
happy now and he's all in yeah for now
because he understands this year is
another
roll of the dice it's another spin of
the wheel to try to add to your legacy
and russell wilson's got a hell of a lot
more of those spins left than aaron
rodgers aaron rodgers is down to let's
say four you're gonna give up one don't
no you don't do the time you don't like
the boss
you don't do the time anymore tom brady
has has ruined that for everyone
you can't i
i i look he ha if aaron rodgers wants to
add to his legacy he can't give up a
full season of football and and if his
problem in green bay is
i don't like upper management as i've
said many times this week with the
caveat that that i have no issue with
upper management at nbc i'd say most
americans have an issue with upper
management wherever they work and they
still show up to work every day so just
because he's upset with mark murphy or
brian gouda kunst he said to kenny mayne
i love my teammates i love my coaches i
love the fans i think he's going to be
there but if he's already decided
that he's not playing at all this year
the time to pull the pin on the grenade
is next friday and you save 20.3 million
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports